[Music]
so
[Music]
ethical angel is a virtual marketplace
where global causes like
charities social enterprises and impact
entrepreneurs
can order hundreds of digital services
for free
including graphic design copywriting
social media posting
logo design and more whether you are
looking for audience mapping to connect
with new supporters
translation to share your messages with
others technical advice to upgrade your
it systems
ethical angel is the free to use
resource you need to get what you need
with just a few
easy clicks
[Music]
death sometimes it can be
unexpected so it's probably about time
you wrote your will
thoughts of mountains of paperwork big
expensive fees
and confusing legal jargon can feel a
bit
overwhelming but it's actually a far
simpler way
at farewell.com you can write your will
in as little as 15 minutes
giving you the confidence to take care
of what really matters
visit farewell.com to start your will
[Music]
today
our mission at quickscreen is to
supersede hospital curtains everywhere
we want to disrupt healthcare and get
rid of those curtains that have been
hanging in hospitals for over 100 years
hospital curtains you may not think
about too much but they're often cleaned
only once a year in the nhs
our solution which michael is showing
here is an easy to clean
retractable privacy screen it can be
wiped down
and is considerably more hygienic than
the curtain
we are transforming the way hospitals
run and how their spaces operate
and during covid we have not only
supplied nightingale hospitals but we
have supplied numerous nhs hospitals
and hospitals around the world as they
look to make more hygienic
[Music]
space
[Music]
opus 2 is a company i established 12
years ago
we specialize in developing software
and providing services for major
litigation
arbitration hearings and public
inquiries across the globe
the software effectively provides a
seamless interface for lawyers
judges arbitrators to access
live transcript interacting with the
documents in the case
which are then hyperlinked in real time
[Music]
you